- [Announcer] This Great
Big Story was made possible
by Wells Fargo.
Established 1852.
Re-established 2018.
- [Narrator] Once a bountiful fish
found in the deep and rocky waters
along the U.S. South Atlantic
coast and the Gulf of Mexico,
overfishing now poses a serious threat
to their ability to reproduce.
This is the snowy grouper.
(gentle music)
The snowy grouper is
named for the white spots
that speckle its scales.
As the groupers grow,
these spots tend to blend
into the fish's natural brown color.
They will often eat crabs and small squid
that they swallow whole
with their large mouths.
Snowy groupers all begin life as females,
but as they age, some become males.
Since the 1990s, overfishing of juveniles
has affected populations,
because not enough fish
reach maturity to change sex.
Regulations were put in
place, but not enough was done
to slow the overfishing of the species.
The snowy grouper is now
listed as vulnerable,
and its populations continue to decline.
This is the snowy grouper.